[موسيقى]
من شيم العرب منذ القدم انهم يتازرون
ويتساندون ويتساعدون بل
ويتسابقون لمساعده المحتاج في الماكل
والمشرب والملبس وحتى المسكن في حال
اشتداد البرد اوقد فان الليل ليل قر
والريح يا هذا ريح صر عسى يرى نارك من يمر
فان جلب الضيفا فانت حر فالبرد احد العلل
الحياتيه والعلل تنقسم الى قسمين علل
نفسيه ومن اسبابها الفقر وعيل الجسميه ومن
اسبابها البرد والعامه يقولون البرد
والقله اساس كل ع
[تصفيق]
والبرد مضر في جميع مراحله فاوله في اول
موسم الخريف والعامه يسمونه بارد اصفري
لان الاجسام تصفر من كثره الامراض والعرب
يقولون توقوا البرد في اوله وتلقوه في
اخره فانه يعمل في الاجساد كعمله في
الاشجار فاوله محرق واخره مورق واخر البرد
في اخر الربيع والعامه يسمونه برد بياع
الخبل عباته والعرب يسمونه ببرد الحسوم
وهو البرد الذي اهلك الله به قوم عاد
سخرها عليهم سبع ليالي وثمانيه ايام من
حسومه فترى القوم فيها صرع كانهم عجاج نقل
خاويه ومن خطوره البرد شبهه العامه بالذئب
وقالوا البرد وجهه وجذيب ما تدري معين
يجيك
[موسيقى]